go to christina ruffini who is in geneva
following the u.s efforts to prevent
russia from invading ukraine christina
good morning
good morning it's a chilly afternoon
here in geneva and there's no reason to
expect tomorrow's talks between the u.s
and russia are going to be all that much
warmer responding to president biden's
comments that russia faces severe
consequences if it invades ukraine the
kremlin said this morning those words
could further escalate the situation
russia shows no sign of backing down
increasing troop numbers on its border
with ukraine and staging active military
drills in belarus overnight cbs news
confirmed the u.s has given permission
for nato allies to rush additional
american-made weapons to ukraine
secretary of state anthony blinken is in
germany today meeting with european
leaders trying to get everyone on the
same page about sanctions then he will
come here to geneva where even though
tensions are high he's already trying to
set the bar low saying not to expect any
major breakthroughs tony
christina rafini for us in geneva
christina thank you very much